all right where do we go speaking of
self we can go here again I'm marking
where I'm gonna drop
[Music]
in the damper quickly review get that
dabbing gonna get a diamond design for
luck get inside defense everyone at this
time yeah go to the Big L building okay
we can hold say building out of the back
right you may come with us
probably we had a two three but getting
an edited part are we I'm never going to
make it it might be okay I don't see why
you following us actually now they go
along I think we're alone now because
you just be any fun oh come on baby my
hope he will be afraid are you going to
nail building we're stay in shape take a
band is known here so just move out leap
to [ __ ] me in Luton bounce baby bounce
oh yeah man cheese
I never wanted the quad I really want to
do it well I never went on the other one
a lot what a lot harder than the below
since many people killed each other
I think jurors is definitely you do
solos is quite hard as well because it's
just you're just head as soon as you see
someone you know to meet John wick if
it's [ __ ] John wick it's over he's
give up the guy who's killed this is
done now please please John wick don't
do it please I'm gonna do it a little
bit in and then I'm gonna do your mother
no that's okay you can be my father I
call you Dada Raja Raja
sorry sure that was my original joke to
play or unknown the other day what when
he said violence is never the answer
even if you're in character I wanted to
tweet like never tell this guy about
Batman
and what does that mean well because
Batman is a character player unknown
things character the real and Batman
punches people for justice my boy
justice for great justice who I judge me
you have a little thing to find the
people stick like all they have the bad
time we're talking about before yo Mike
let's go about winning squad a key is a
km up here a few minutes ago in a
sandwich boy then he's had that I'm a
bad man what the [ __ ] oh my god I don't
have the basics Joey found one that's
okay guys Brad did you lose the other
big building
I've looted just the two outside the
gate on the south side okay I've been in
this one yet you want going on okay so
this little outside play quietly there's
a car game time there's a car on the
blue marker just to go to it's not
really normally win because it has to
run quite far there must be a yeah it's
gonna be a bridge game it's going to
land yeah we should just get a boat I
don't want to [ __ ] early doors boat
he'll float race you've got a right ugly
boat
I should add dolphins in the game we eat
just ride them over yeah I'll call me in
their shoes at the beginning you either
pick up a gun or a speak with animals
spell
I don't talk about my people
I summon a manatee okay I'm ready to go
if you guys aren't caught up is mr. Chen
funding is useful I never find remotely
painkillers your funders I have a lot of
a lot of [ __ ] to share Med twice do you
think there's a car over here well
sometimes there's one over here
somewhere so I think we're less likely
to run into trouble if we had enough
direction of the road I'll spread out a
little bit just to see if I can spot one
spread them cheeks spread it boy John
wick is coming Oh see any cars no in
Jerusalem full coverage of the bounce
that road then usually there's there's a
lot of cars on this road yeah we'll keep
me it's just that there's probably quite
a lot of people of the thing always a
car this buggy it'll leave that kick up
meet me thinking but to shoot to shoot a
[ __ ] there's a buggy dead ahead
blue I think there's also bike over
there six needs bean okay to be Alice
curves what do you want to on the blower
I don't see anything with buggies to
know there is get me a balloon remember
at all what a buggy only seeds too
it's okay boys I can set on the hood
sexy you guys go on without me mate but
I'm right behind you
is there yeah yeah I get the buggy I'll
go for the bike lose my bike
there's your bike over here okay it's
pretty far away but people can't drive I
can drive you to the block and come back
me again no no no it's good
yes okay we need to find a boat where I
don't know where they spawn on
and
[Music]
and then video jump boom boom then I
want to have an SMG down the back
we're going to drive me today
bouncing uber have to track the blue
I'll be your driver today you'll find a
selection of peanuts great stop talking
to me I'll tell you wow they're Mexicans
coming over here stealing all of our
jobs all those jobs who want so bad
exactly do another [ __ ] job no one
wants to do this is my family invaded
and sold this country fair and square
fair and square not like what do you do
the back
[Music]
all this trivia it's really good
building getting in it
yeah there's no way there's anyone
indeed there might be
wow that's that team 165 behind the
green has get to the beach don't worry
about get the same look out guess the
theme Hank the missions find a boat I
don't see no boat [ __ ] around fighting
them we can swim across that's a boat on
the other side of the beach today's
challenge of all these you pit I just
wanted to look cool for the stream where
is a boat on the other side keep going
oh yeah
and low graphic that would be working at
I got my my Swedish Eagle very much I'm
pretty I'm pretty amazing can read this
motorcycle I'm saying to eat [ __ ] right
now get it boy oh boat
all rap we did it in branch suitum okay
no should we yeah it should be
[ __ ] the bread shop on the left side on
these rock okay good where the fluid I
guess your game after all
what if I am what are you gonna do that
it straight boy because I like dressing
up like women okay there's more shipping
containers favorite that's good but
they've been brought together a new
program for the old that we're being
came with mouth I think is the most
effective thing we have a swim for a
long time yeah the boats are so typical
are running out of gas port I have
another boat right there alright okay
another boat right there alright all the
lot of time they they I mean yeah you
can circle coming in if it talks to some
reason close off the island yeah well
say we go we go up again and then we go
down we want to get to a fire
well let's see with a circle and we can
just see that here in the middle of
water in testicle weight we do not waste
time I think not listen in we're not
listening feeling very much in Swedish
he's got zero military practice minutes
no we have AG dates they're just about
forfeiting I'm 46 generation Roman
Americans we shoot Dillon without
military that atrocities that's a drug
but it's not tactic that's the thing
this requires tact you just pause they
go for the right yeah yeah there's no
tags and there's a I might need you to
get that yeah when we stop all gasp do
you go for the crane
well we don't pretend that American
right everybody listen we what here's
what we do we ignore filius it's gone no
in Swedish and dryer I'll get to the top
ten and you just go [ __ ] crazy in
coq10 you go full America murica with a
shooting free oh my god congratulation
Magnum awm nice are you dropping me at
all that weight did it drop to the
ground
would you continue a little deep way I
actually want that alright circle I have
any time for time you have anyone
anything
[ __ ] I can't get up wait let me just
adjust my [ __ ] one second hey hell yeah
nice like one of those songs on the ride
and my driving Phil Blackwood's way I
want to reload okay no I shall drive up
and we like let's just drive into the
blue that will be the safest route
why don't we still wait for they're not
blue that never it's definitely on this
island we need to procure a vehicle
these Hill pier are amazing to live in
so if your mom before 3rd generation
Roman y-yeah why go to the beach
Normandy we have to remember the ELMO
remember the Alamo I don't even know
that means a bunch of America fight
Nixon that like the one where they put
like the last band one in our Spanish
yeah the last and where everybody did
that because these sounds has been pray
that there's just a little bit of loot
laughs I'm probably not being anyone
there could be another drop in the water
now you know that's why I like the folks
very accurately listen Bible dad fight
in Mexican can you know that's true
I mean it as far as I'm concerned that's
proof I don't know anything about me can
tell you whatever yeah yeah that's all
we fought the Romans to India and
they're only Americans learn about
American history the rest of the world
can give a [ __ ] about your country 9/11
never forget because it's not history
it's just like yesterday last week I
went to the store only thing I remember
about American history is the Civil War
in Titanic and that's about it I
remember I planted you know I know the
[ __ ] that they'd full-speed you in
American military gives not even
American history
yeah that's like a speaker they really
got Leonardo DiCaprio in it with a
little America [ __ ] cultural
appropriation where did the don't you
think was it from yeah England that's my
fill of England against us good for each
Paul Remus I think it left you know my
you know I'm related to the captain of
the Titanic
she'd like he's like my great great
great great great Jean King out there
buddy and I they really ruined his life
in that movie to kind of [ __ ] made
him look like a prick made it look like
a prick he might have been but as far as
I as far as I was away I like know I
think that they wanted to break the
record so like he was under instruction
by investors to do it most likely so sly
carry every time someone had to use like
a glass of iced water each like it
triggered and freaked out as it gets
closer to your lips no yeah I don't
really have I have one of those weird
like flashbacks that they have in loose
as they touch something you guys do you
like I'm going down with the ship
Brad where are you heading I'm gonna go
and take a little peek around here oh no
Brad last time we played remember who
used to take the peaks and we had bad
yeah I was right there's a car over here
dude we need a car alright we'll drive
it here then can you need it for time
mmm I have a holographic I'll take the
port I'm a dick actually Brad you need a
4-time no no go on
[ __ ] me the game's just [ __ ] tapped
me out how do you not want to I have a
folder okay extra fortune I throw it in
I just don't have any magical oh you're
good there you go
dropped everything I don't need and then
take this Kent and teary your uber
driver is one minute away
yeah the drop solution that I don't need
originally aunt where are we going
somewhere
what's going to steal in the car and
hang out the video and listen put it
right here
alright what are you got in terms of MIT
because I put 20 bandages in three
energy three is you want painkillers in
bandages and interstate filler we need
to kill some people
I got first aid med kit I'll give you
one Friday then
and then the rest you don't need you can
in the car
hey guys I'll just hit the hair with
this message make more I got it
I've just drawn a I need this I painted
this wall paint on in circles on my face
that gets smaller and to like the answer
shake that ass
yeah well guys you want to shoot me in
my [ __ ] just just shut the man's eye
on just one shot please
maybe maybe - I got a pan you in a pan
can't aim of the pan you'll die don't
see my patient I'll explode Nicole ended
really blocked everything I want to save
your box awm no get out of the car come
on drive this off the cliff if you don't
do that oh I think you see me okay all
right give it a spike yes - drop number
de tres come up if you kill him he has
to get out okay are you ready
[Music]
Hey ha ha
that's got a tingle baby whoa the circus
closing
oh hell yeah I think it's better because
we already loaded Billings we're better
off in the rocks oh yeah a hundred
percent Eva close it here this is the
best place ever to be be right here in
the vehicle I just don't think we have
the men although we don't really have
the [ __ ] to sustain the final circle I
guess but well we'll just have to assume
we can kill some people
yeah how'd the truck know y'all leaving
who died like a [ __ ] mythical
creature try yeah we should probably
hide the truck pull it down here I'm a
bush never find it in the bush I mean
it's on top of the hill there look at
the top of it anyway the Olmec [ __ ]
camping spot here guys did you bring a
tent I got a pan I'm going to set up my
sleeping bag over here sort of alien
cooks makes me cool at night I bet
there's some swallow eggs in this tree
you cook up a pan just shield a bunch
and get it good in hot yeah crank crank
it up and just wake up that Jeep we're
cooking on the Block well we can cook it
on the end run off the tree yes sound
like Christopher Lee is little the
engine block yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
way too credit in it isn't it in it yeah
if people do come running across this
bill to us they are so [ __ ] with that
aw in on them going for one with the 308
right it does so much [ __ ] damage 134
it's insane yeah 134 it does it's like
almost three aks rice to juice okay
Jesus Christ miss Jackson
it's John wig yeah I hope we don't see
him is gonna come on console filtered
pencil and Wooper added baba yaga I
don't even know what they say I just
know they call him something than they
translate to boogey man because they
have that weird [ __ ] subtitled their
name in that movie like fly out into the
Sun and [ __ ] it just goes all weird
typography any level student typography
alright sir no one here yet this is
insane look at this circle they're
always at the base fighting is probably
Muslim come on circle yeah dude
okay oh yeah all right people people who
were here there will be people in these
hills yeah someone make sure it will
contact right person
okay Brian you check right I'll check
left and straight I'll sit over by this
like tree area but it's out of the
circle I'll just like Baba Yaga will
probably get me what's the [ __ ] is there
in this area even like the only houses
in this area are the ones who are absurd
there's a houses over there
people will come a trip to the people
that run for houses Anubis fun so we
should be able to [ __ ] them up car
coming we're from left site go into the
houses yes okay
till they do they went to drinking soon
they're going in the house wait don't
shoot I don't think anyone should shoot
foot feelings unless they come below
I'll wait for a head shot but I mean
okay Oh dope ass shot they think they're
people in there yeah oh yeah there's no
way in the middle building their India
there in them clothes if they're in here
as well actually right here blue one
blue marker yeah that's the only one I
thought well yeah whatever there's two
in there oh no they're on the moves
they're going to the big building now
okay they're actually milling around in
the middle between the three I'm a man
if you at that [ __ ] a WN over here
the thing is I think another team will
come here yeah we don't want to attract
anyone right now yeah let them I and
fight not only here there's no point in
engagement like sure they don't see you
yeah another one see me I'm the Baba
Yaga don't we don't even all they say is
someone in Chapter write down the word a
hold on me I know it means boogeyman it
like [ __ ] Russian or Slovak or
something but is that the only team
those three yeah
yes okay well looks like they're gonna
they're gonna camp in there then a third
person here but I keep moving
I need to get in circle before the
circle get to me you make sure they're
not checking the windows he was a third
person there probably I mean they're not
looking at the beach most likely they're
probably on the other side
yeah I think there is a loser in this
building now I think they went into the
big building so they could have the
second floors on it I think they're in
the brown building I saw them all
running yeah this one the blue I marked
it blue all right here we go the circle
is definitely going to move us so we're
probably not don't [ __ ] them now
well wait for them to run out first we
don't use the phone in the car well that
booty they're gonna be here until we use
oh thank you
always not that follow these littles
here would be the best if we can get to
those hills ahead of her
we could let them run I I think it's
better to make them run when they start
running across the open field figs we
just [ __ ] pop up and Baba Yaga the
[ __ ] out so I go to the right of the car
this in the buildings they can't be at
the commune both of me
pull up to the [ __ ]
great thing one roll to the wall so we
can just complete I'm better I'm better
off in a different another car coming in
Jesus
these goes over the hill
what if you're playing on it I'm going
full Solid Snake I'm going to creep up
this wall I need a visual on them
they're probably going to go for their
own car right you know they're just
going to run alright Phil if you go to
the far end yeah where you're going to
keep going to the end in third person
around the corner when you see them
going Felix needs to fire the first shot
because he needs to just because it's
pretty much just a [ __ ] instant dead
right yeah
can't see them though now it's a bet
areas that I'm sure that they've already
left and we just didn't see them but
let's now we're taking a gamble right
now we've got 34 seconds so let's start
going
it's weird our way I don't even hear
them in the building to be fair you want
to throw smokes now they're still in the
Sicilian oh yeah getting shot in that
window
Felix watch window they're in there
you'll see them moving around to get to
where I am
we've got nine seconds actually which we
done left well right now here they go
here they go you ready okay
one down right two down
right keep on ringing I don't know
whether they're gay if actually dad said
run run for the [ __ ] hills I know I
know
run - right here get over here is it
he'll always [ __ ] him perfect look at
this [ __ ] Hill dude nice I was
[ __ ] good job
I was cranked that was [ __ ] it they
didn't know what the [ __ ] was going on
dude it was [ __ ] beautiful
a pink three gear oh we're pulled up
over West 285 that's really close by I
need to hear that really quick Amanda
this could end on the [ __ ] Road never
good
it means you just have to you know
divide it will you be the last ones in
there and the best we're best up going
north around the circle and then going
along the actual road I think the
[ __ ] car it's over there walk that
far away in 12 left crawl
to scroll to the grass 48 seconds we're
on we're not going to make it just keep
going again
so where's that rock the rock on the
right so that you Tim know two five five
high sentence off of rice and frown I
don't know where there is a teammate
sorry Justin guy coming in down as well
down I'm not dead they're both down two
down now don't forget pick them up or
crawl into the pick them up I don't see
I just see two people no no so guy you
get down in run sorry nice the dead guy
all right yeah on run run no no Greg a
yeah yeah I'm being shot there's a [ __ ]
kind of cars over here dude those shots
from the West we got to move in there's
a team to the or the yellow marker it's
by the car over there by the car
can't get a [ __ ] bit H time [ __ ]
duck what a [ __ ]
move it oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] - Liv Liv
Liv Liv Liv Liv list so they visited and
Lily damn [ __ ] they did the same cool
there's we have to run towards them
which sucks we have plenty of covered up
I'm moving in there on the yellow marker
yeah there's also one on this blue
Montcalm really I think I did catch up
I'm dead nice inside yeah level 3 hell
minions today [ __ ] beautiful G right
do all your boosts if you get your boost
to the top you can boost aim in that
last little tiny bit there okay yeah
okay what Nathan [ __ ] you have I will
[ __ ] I'm just down to an m16 and a
UMP I have a lot of I have 5 smokes
so worth it on each other this is mom
does n with you no that was Kenny I
don't want to move in within a double um
I rather stay covered while you guys
move in well if you look at where I'm
crawling towards right now yeah there's
a little dip in the road look which is
perfect too far for me I'm just gonna
have to move right there's two left and
three of us did you go forth in because
you can have to move soon I'm almost
anyway they're probably in the grads as
well
unless they're on the left of me and I
don't think they are I think they're
over the road which means they're Navin
shot at me yet and I'm never afraid
well it's possible we like trench
warfare in the [ __ ] out this right I'm
throwing it
I don't know episode I'm looking for I'm
trying to see am I still behind the
vehicle
I don't know you're in this I think I
think they are because they are
technically in the circle we could shoot
the car make it explode
that's it would be very [ __ ] clutch
with that circle Ken oh yeah I have to
come to us right full auto
that's mine that's for any smokes we
need this milk over there okay it's fine
just keep an eye out just oh they look
and take al comfortable you can if you
can keep I own I are on the Left what do
they do it for the manner they know that
how to run to us the [ __ ] they're
probably you see where I am
they're probably in the same [ __ ]
position on the other side right there
see the only possible place like yeah
yeah yeah I am looking at the car
because that's what I think they are by
the rock that's where I would hide if I
were them yeah in co2 and wait they're
popping out they're popping out they
come down one down I'm moving into the
circle these are 10 seconds which means
a compliment I'm in the circle image I
see him he's in the car no wait I don't
I'm stupid prisoners just getting just
getting this little circle behind a
little bit early I'm I'm perfect up here
there is moving it's moving
one down one left on the left yeah we
did it
boom boys what a [ __ ] game chicken
dead wish chicken dinner
hell yeah I was sexy as [ __ ] boys that
was a good guy that was that was SWAT
team level [ __ ] [ __ ] at the end once
we took that first team we just moved
through the area like yeah yeah flow
let's [ __ ] play Jesus Christ the
plague Alpha Team played John we did
John went in once you get killed by John
wick you get small piece of his power
yeah that's what happens how many kills
did you get five